Dara met him in a mental hospital. They were both patients. They had group therapy together. So she knew all his secrets, even before they started seeing each other.
达拉是在一家精神病院遇到他的。他们当时都是病人。他们一起参加团体治疗。所以，甚至在他们开始交往之前，她就已经知道了关于他的一切秘密。
And they told us not to get involved and that just made it even more fun to get involved. He was very funny. He was so funny. He just made me laugh all the time. And he was really fun to be with.
他们告诉我们不要深陷其中，但这反而让这种关系变得更加有趣。他非常幽默。他太搞笑了。他总是让我开怀大笑。和他在一起真的很开心。
Things continued, even after they got out of the hospital. He was officially diagnosed as manic depressive. But he was manic a lot. She was depressive.
即便是在他们出院后，事情仍在继续。他被正式诊断为躁郁症。但他大部分时间都处于躁狂状态。而她则处于抑郁状态。
I guess we complemented each other in a way. But he was-- whoa. He was whacked, man. He'd be in my apartment. He'd be walking like a chicken and stuff. And I don't know. He did anything to make me laugh.
我想我们在某种程度上是互补的。但他——哇。他真是个疯子。他会在我的公寓里像只鸡一样走来走去之类的。我不知道。为了逗我笑，他什么都做得出来。
We were kind of on and off and then we decided to live together. He's a little different. I mean, I liked the crazy part of him. I liked that funny, wacky. But then, it's weird. It's different when you're living with it. It's like you have the stand up comedian with you 24 hours. It gets to be a little like snap out of it, can't you act normal? Can't you just act mellow? And no. No, that wasn't happening.
我们的关系分分合合，后来决定同居。他有点与众不同。我是说，我喜欢他疯狂的那一面。我喜欢那种风趣、古怪的感觉。但后来，这很奇怪。当你真正和他生活在一起时，感觉就不同了。就像你身边24小时跟着一个单口相声演员。这让人有点受不了，心想“你能不能正常点？能不能表现得随和点？”但不行。不，那是不可能的。
It wasn't happening because he was after all, mentally ill.
那是不可能的，因为毕竟，他患有精神疾病。
He was just driving me crazy. Because also, we would be in the grocery store and it would take him so long to buy one item. He'd be looking at it, and then comparing it to another one. And then to another one. And then he was smart, so he'd be figuring everything out mathematically. And then by grams and stuff. And I would be like no way. I can't handle this anymore. I just couldn't do it.
他快把我逼疯了。因为我们去杂货店时，他买一件商品都要花很长时间。他会盯着它看，然后把它和另一件比较。接着再跟另一件比较。而且他很聪明，所以他会用数学计算一切。按克数什么的。我会觉得，没门。我受不了了。我真的没法忍受。
For some reason he also thought-- he also treated me like I was the crazy one. I always thought he was crazy, I guess. So I don't think that worked.
出于某种原因，他也认为——他甚至把我当作那个疯子。我想一直以来，我都认为他才是那个疯子。所以我认为这行不通。
Although there are plenty of people with severe and debilitating mental illness just as often the line between crazy and not crazy is blurry. So many different kinds of behavior fall into both categories. And I think what captures our attention and our hearts when we talk with someone who's mentally ill, is not how they're different from us, but how they're the same.
虽然有很多人患有严重且致残的精神疾病，但疯与不疯之间的界限往往很模糊。许多不同类型的行为都属于这两个范畴。我认为当我们与精神疾病患者交谈时，吸引我们注意力和打动我们内心的，不是他们与我们有何不同，而是他们与我们有何相同之处。
Well, from WBEZ in Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program we bring you stories of the sanity that is part of mental illness. People who stand on the borderline between sanity and sickness. Act One, Girl, Interrupted. A movie has been made out of Susanna Kaysen's memoir, Girl, Interrupted , about a mental hospital. If you've never read the book, it is one of the most remarkable pieces of nonfiction writing of the last few years. We have an excerpt.
你好，这里是芝加哥的WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台联合播出的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，我们将为您带来有关精神疾病中所包含的理性的故事。那些站在理智与疾病边缘的人们。第一幕，《移魂女郎》。苏珊娜·凯森的关于一家精神病院的回忆录《移魂女郎》已被改编成电影。如果您从未读过这本书，它是过去几年中最出色的非虚构作品之一。我们选取了一个片段。
Act Two, Guided By Voices. We also have this tape made by people who actually hear voices in their heads. And the tape is designed to simulate what it is that they hear. Act Three, Plague of Tics. David Sedaris explains the voices that he hears in his head. Act Four, You Don't Have to Be Crazy to Work Here, But It Helps. What it's like if you hold the keys to the asylum, but your grip on them is not too steady. Stay with us.
第二幕，《幻听》。我们还有一份由真正能听到脑海中声音的人制作的录音带。这份录音带旨在模拟他们所听到的内容。第三幕，《抽动症瘟疫》。大卫·塞达里斯解释了他脑海中听到的声音。第四幕，《你不需要疯也能在这里工作，但有病会有帮助》。如果你掌管着疯人院的钥匙，但你的把握并不太稳，那会是种什么样的体验。请继续收听。
Act One, at the age of 18, after a brief appointment with a psychiatrist who she had never met before, Susanna Kaysen entered McLean Psychiatric Hospital. Her book, Girl, Interrupted, describes her stay on the ward for teenage girls, where she spent most of two years. It's partly an account of what it's like to have certain mental illnesses and partly an account of everyday life on the ward. The nurses the girls liked and didn't like, the doctors, and the way the young women on the ward interacted with each other.
第一幕，18岁那年，在与一位素未谋面的精神科医生进行了一次简短的会面后，苏珊娜·凯森住进了麦克林精神病院。她的书《移魂女郎》描述了她在少女病房的经历，她在那里度过了两年的大部分时间。这既是一部关于患有特定精神疾病是什么样子的记录，也是一部关于病房日常生活的记录。护士们，女孩们喜欢和不喜欢的护士，医生们，以及病房里年轻女性们相互交流的方式。
One day a second Lisa arrived. We called her buy her full name, Lisa Cody, to distinguish her from the real Lisa, who remained named simply, Lisa, like a queen.
有一天，第二个丽莎来了。为了把她和真正的丽莎区分开，我们叫她的全名——丽莎·科迪。真正的丽莎依然简称为“丽莎”，像女王一样。
The Lisas became friends. One of their favorite activities was having phone conversations. The three phone booths near the double locked double doors were our only privacy. We could go in one and shut the door. Even the craziest person could sit in a phone booth and have a private conversation, though only with herself. The nurses had lists of permitted numbers for each of us. When we picked up the phone, a nurse would answer.
两个丽莎成了朋友。她们最喜欢的活动之一就是打电话。双重加锁双开门旁边的三个电话亭是我们唯一的隐私空间。我们可以进去一个，关上门。即使是最疯狂的人也可以坐在电话亭里进行私密谈话，尽管只是和她自己谈。护士们有我们每个人的获准拨打号码列表。当我们拿起电话时，护士会接听。
Hello, we'd say. This is Georgina, or Cynthia, or Polly. I want to call 555-4270.
“你好，”我们会说，“我是乔治娜、辛西娅或波莉。我想拨打555-4270。”
That's not on your list the nurse would say. Then the line would go dead. But there was still the quiet dusty phone booth and the old fashioned black receiver with its sharp, dorsal ridge.
“那不在你的名单上，”护士会说。然后线路就会中断。但那里依然有安静、尘土飞扬的电话亭，以及带有锋利背脊的老式黑色听筒。
The Lisas had phone conversations. Each one got in a booth, folded the door shut and yelled into her receiver. When the nurse answered, Lisa yelled, "Off the line!" Then the Lisas got on with their conversation. Sometimes they yelled insults. Sometimes they yelled about their plans for the day.
两个丽莎进行过电话通话。每个人都进入一个亭子，折叠关上门，然后对着听筒大喊。当护士接听时，丽莎大喊：“别占线！”然后两个丽莎开始她们的对话。有时她们大喊辱骂对方的话。有时她们大喊关于当天的计划。
"Want to go over to the cafeteria for dinner?" Lisa Cody would yell.
“想去食堂吃晚饭吗？”丽莎·科迪会喊道。
But Lisa was restricted to the ward, so she'd have to yell back something like, "Why do you want to eat that slop with all those psychotics?"
但丽莎被限制在病房里，所以她不得不回喊道：“你为什么想和那些精神病患者一起吃那种烂泥一样的东西？”
To which Lisa Cody would yell, "What do you think you are?"
丽莎·科迪会喊道：“你以为你是什么？”
"Sociopath!" Lisa would yell proudly.
“反社会人格者！”丽莎骄傲地大喊。
Lisa Cody didn't have a diagnosis yet.
丽莎·科迪当时还没有被诊断。
Cynthia was depressive. Polly and Georgina were schizophrenic. I had a character disorder. Sometimes they called it a personality disorder.
辛西娅是抑郁症。波莉和乔治娜是精神分裂症。我患有性格障碍。有时他们称之为个性障碍。
When I got my diagnosis, it didn't sound serious. But after a while, it sounded more ominous than other people's. I imagine my character as a plate or shirt that had been manufactured incorrectly and was therefore useless. When she had been with us a month or so, Lisa Cody got a diagnosis. She was a sociopath too. She was happy because she wanted to be like Lisa in all things.
当我得到诊断结果时，听起来并不严重。但过了一段时间，它听起来比其他人的更不祥。我把我的性格想象成一个制造错误的盘子或衬衫，因此毫无用处。和我们住在一起大约一个月后，丽莎·科迪得到了诊断结果。她也是个反社会人格者。她很高兴，因为她想在各方面都像丽莎。
Lisa was not so happy because she had been the only sociopath among us. We are very rare, she told me once. And mostly, we are men.
丽莎并不太高兴，因为她曾经是我们中唯一的反社会人格者。“我们非常罕见，”她有一次告诉我，“而且大多数都是男性。”
After Lisa Cody got her diagnosis, the Lisas started making more trouble. Acting out, the nurses said. We knew what it was. The real Lisa was proving that Lisa Cody wasn't a sociopath.
在丽莎·科迪得到诊断结果后，两个丽莎开始制造更多麻烦。护士们说是“演戏”。我们知道那是什么。真正的丽莎在证明丽莎·科迪不是反社会人格者。
Lisa tongued her sleeping meds for a week, took them all at once and stayed zonked for a day and a night. Lisa Cody managed to save only four of hers. And when she took them, she puked.
丽莎把安眠药藏在舌下含了一周，然后一次性全部吞下，昏睡了一天一夜。丽莎·科迪只攒下了四片药。当她服下它们时，她呕吐了。
Lisa put a cigarette out on her arm at 6:30 in the morning while the nurses were changing shifts. That afternoon, Lisa Cody burned a tiny welt on her wrist and spent the next 20 minutes running cold water on it.
丽莎在凌晨6点半护士换班时，在手臂上熄灭了一根香烟。那天下午，丽莎·科迪在手腕上烫了一个小水泡，并花了接下来的20分钟用冷水冲洗它。
Then they had a life history battle. Lisa wormed out of Lisa Cody that she'd grown up in Greenwich, Connecticut. "Greenwich, Connecticut," she sneered. "No sociopath could emerge from there. Were you a debutante too?"
然后她们进行了一场生平经历的较量。丽莎从丽莎·科迪口中套出她是在康涅狄格州的格林威治长大的。“康涅狄格州的格林威治，”她冷笑道，“没有反社会人格者会从那里出现。你以前也是个社交名媛吗？”
Speed, black beauties, coke, heroine, Lisa had done it all. Lisa Cody said she'd been a junkie too. She rolled her sleeve back to show her tracks. Faint scratches along the vein as if once, years before, she had tangled with a rose bush.
兴奋剂、黑美人药丸、可卡因、海洛因，丽莎都试过。丽莎·科迪说她也曾是个瘾君子。她卷起袖子展示她的静脉注射痕迹。静脉上是一些淡淡的抓痕，仿佛多年前曾与玫瑰丛纠缠过。
"A suburban junkie," said Lisa. "You were playing that's what."
“一个郊区瘾君子，”丽莎说，“你那是在演戏，那是肯定的。”
"Hey, man. Junk's junk," Lisa Cody protested.
“嘿，伙计。毒品就是毒品，”丽莎·科迪抗议道。
Lisa pushed her sleeve up to her elbow and shoved her arm under Lisa Cody's nose. Her arm was studded with pale brown lumps, gnarled and authentic. "These," said Lisa, "are tracks, man. Later for your tracks."
丽莎把袖子推到手肘处，将手臂伸到丽莎·科迪的鼻子底下。她的手臂上布满了淡棕色的肿块，凹凸不平且货真价实。“这些，”丽莎说，“才是痕迹，伙计。以后别提你的那些痕迹了。”
Lisa Cody was beaten, but she didn't have the sense to give up. She still sat beside Lisa at breakfast and hall meeting. She still waited in the phone booth for the call that didn't come.
丽莎·科迪被打败了，但她没有意识到要放弃。她依然在早餐和走廊会议上坐在丽莎身边。她依然在电话亭里等待那永远不会来的电话。
"I gotta get rid of her," said Lisa.
“我得除掉她，”丽莎说。
"You're mean," Polly said.
“你真刻薄，”波莉说。
"[BLEEP] bitch," said Lisa.
“[脏话]婊子，”丽莎说。
"Who?" asked Cynthia, Polly's protector. But Lisa didn't bother to clarify.
“谁？”波莉的保护者辛西娅问道。但丽莎懒得澄清。
One evening when the nurses walked the halls at dusk to turn on the lights that made our ward as bright and jarring as a penny arcade, they found every light bulb gone. Not broken, vanished. We knew who'd done it. The question was, where had she put them? It was hard to search in the darkness. Even the light bulbs in our rooms were gone.
一天傍晚，当护士们在黄昏巡视病房打开灯光，使我们的病房变得像投币游戏厅一样明亮刺眼时，她们发现每一个灯泡都不见了。不是碎了，是消失了。我们知道是谁干的。问题是，她把它们藏在哪儿了？在黑暗中搜查很困难。连我们房间里的灯泡都不见了。
"Lisa has the true artistic temperament," said Georgina.
“丽莎有着真正的艺术家气质，”乔治娜说。
"Just hunt," said the head nurse. "Everybody hunt."
“去搜，”护长说，“大家去搜。”
Lisa sat out the hunt in the TV room. It was Lisa Cody who found them as she was meant to. She was probably planning to sit out the hunt as well, in the place that held memories of better days. She must've felt some resistance when she tried to fold the door back. There were dozens of light bulbs inside. But she persevered, just as she had persevered with Lisa.
丽莎坐在电视室里没参加搜查。正是丽莎·科迪发现了它们，就像她注定会做的那样。她可能也打算在那片承载着美好日子记忆的地方避开搜查。当她试图把门折叠回去时，她一定感觉到了一些阻力。里面有几十个灯泡。但她坚持了下来，就像她对待丽莎一样坚持。
The crunch and clatter brought us also scampering down to the phone booths. "Broken," said Lisa Cody. Everyone asked Lisa how she'd done it. But all she would say was, I've got a long, skinny arm.
破碎声和叮当声把我们也都吸引到了电话亭。“碎了，”丽莎·科迪说。每个人都问丽莎她是怎么做到的。但她只会说：“我的胳膊很长，很细。”
Lisa Cody disappeared two days later. Somewhere between our ward and the cafeteria she slipped away. Nobody ever found her, though the search went on for more than a week.
丽莎·科迪两天后消失了。在我们病房和食堂之间的某个地方，她溜走了。虽然搜寻持续了一周多，但没人找到她。
"She couldn't take this place," said Lisa. And though we listened for a trace of jealousy in her voice, we didn't hear one.
“她受不了这个地方，”丽莎说。尽管我们试图从她的声音中捕捉到一丝嫉妒，但我们没听出来。
Some months later, Lisa ran off again while she was being taken to a gynecology consult at the Mass General. Two days she managed this time.
几个月后，丽莎在被送往麻省总医院进行妇科会诊时又跑了。这次她撑了两天。
When she got back she looked especially pleased with herself.
当她回来时，她看起来对自己特别满意。
"I saw Lisa Cody," she said.
“我看到丽莎·科迪了，”她说。
"Ooh," said Georgina.
“噢，”乔治娜说。
Polly shook her head.
波莉摇了摇头。
"She's a real junkie now," said Lisa, smiling.
“她现在是个真正的瘾君子了，”丽莎笑着说。
One girl among us had set herself on fire. She used gasoline. She was too young to drive at the time. I wondered how she had gotten hold of it. Had she walked to her neighborhood garage and told them her father's car had run out of gas? I couldn't look at her without thinking about it.
我们中间有一个女孩曾试图自焚。她用了汽油。当时她还太小，不能开车。我很好奇她是怎么弄到汽油的。她是不是走到社区修车厂，告诉他们她父亲的车没油了？我不看她就无法不去想这件事。
I think the gasoline had settled in her collarbones, forming pools there beside her shoulders. Because her neck and cheeks were scarred the most. The scars were thick ridges, alternating bright pink and white in stripes up from her neck. They were so tough and wide that she couldn't turn her head, but had to swivel her entire upper torso if she wanted to see a person standing next to her.
我想汽油在她锁骨处停留，在肩膀旁形成了水洼。因为她的脖子和脸颊受损最严重。伤疤是厚厚的凸起，从脖子上蜿蜒而上，呈鲜粉色和白色相间的条纹。它们太硬太宽了，导致她无法转头，如果想看身边站着的人，必须整个上半身转动。
Scar tissue has no character. It's not like skin. It doesn't show age or illness, or pallor or tan. It has no pores, no hair, no wrinkles. It's like a slip cover. It shields and disguises what's beneath. That's why we grow it. We have something to hide.
疤痕组织没有特性。它不像皮肤。它不会显示年龄或疾病、苍白或晒黑。它没有毛孔、没有汗毛、没有皱纹。它就像一个套子。它保护并掩盖了下面的东西。这就是为什么我们要生长它。我们有东西要隐藏。
Her name was Polly. This name must have seemed ridiculous to her in the days or months when she was planning to set herself on fire, but it suited her well in her slip-covered survivor life. She was never unhappy. She was kind and comforting to those who were unhappy. She never complained. She always had time to listen to other people's complaints. She was faultless in her impermeable, tight, pink and white casing.
她的名字叫波莉。在她计划自焚的那几天或几个月里，这个名字对她来说一定显得很荒谬，但它很适合她那覆盖着套子的幸存者生活。她从不忧郁。她对那些忧郁的人很友善、很安慰。她从不抱怨。她总是乐于倾听别人的抱怨。在她那坚不可摧、紧绷的粉白色外壳下，她是完美的。
Whatever had driven her, whispered "die" in her once perfect-- now scarred-- ear, she had emulated it.
无论是什么驱使她，在她曾经完美——现在却布满伤疤——的耳朵里低语着“去死”，她都顺从了它。
Why did she do it? Nobody knew. Nobody dared to ask. Because what courage. Who had the courage to burn herself? 20 aspirin, a little slit alongside the veins of the arm, maybe even a bad half hour standing on a roof. We've all had those. And somewhat more dangerous things, like putting a gun in your mouth. But you put it there, you taste it, it's cold and greasy. Your finger is on the trigger and you find that a whole world lies between this moment and the moment you've been planning when you'll pull the trigger.
她为什么要这么做？没人知道。没人敢问。因为那是何等的勇气。谁有勇气烧掉自己？20片阿司匹林，手臂静脉旁割一道小口子，甚至在屋顶上度过一个糟糕的半小时。我们都有过这样的时刻。还有一些更危险的事情，比如把枪放进嘴里。但你放进去了，尝到了它的味道，又冷又油腻。你的手指扣在扳机上，你发现这一刻和你计划扣动扳机的那一刻之间隔着整个世界。
That world defeats you. You put the gun back in the drawer. You'll have to find another way.
那个世界打败了你。你把枪放回抽屉里。你还得找另一种方法。
What was that moment like for her, the moment she lit the match? Had she already tried roofs and guns and aspirin? Or was it just an inspiration?
那对她来说是什么样的一刻，那个点燃火柴的一刻？她已经试过屋顶、枪支和阿司匹林了吗？还是那只是一时的灵感？
I had an inspiration once. I woke up one morning and I knew that today I had to swallow 50 aspirin. It was my task, my job for the day.
我有过一次灵感。一天早上醒来，我知道今天我必须吞下50片阿司匹林。这是我的任务，我今天的工作。
I lined them up on my desk and took them one by one, counting. But it's not the same as what she did. I could have stopped at 10 or 30. And I could have done what I did do, which was go onto the street and faint. 50 aspirin is a lot of aspirin. But going onto the street and fainting is like putting the gun back in the drawer. She lit the match.
我把它们排在书桌上，一颗一颗数着服下。但那和我做的事情不一样。我在10片或30片的时候就能停下。我可以像我做的那样，走到街上晕倒。50片阿司匹林确实很多。但走到街上晕倒就像把枪放回抽屉里。她点燃了火柴。
Where? In the garage at home where she wouldn't set anything else on fire? Out in a field? In a high school gym? In an empty swimming pool? Somebody found her, but not for a while.
在哪里？在家里车库里，她不会在那儿点燃别的东西？在田野里？在高中体育馆？在空的游泳池里？有人找到了她，但不是立刻。
Who would kiss a person like that, a person with no skin? She was 18 before this thought occurred to her. She'd spent a year with us.
谁会吻这样一个没有皮肤的人？直到这个念头出现，她才18岁。她和我们在一起住了一年。
Other people stormed and screamed and cringed and cried. Polly watched and smiled. She sat by people who were frightened and her presence calmed them. Her smile wasn't mean, it was understanding. Life was hellish, she knew that. But her smile hinted she'd burned all that out of her. Her smile with a little bit superior. We wouldn't have the courage to burn it out of ourselves, but she understood that too. Everyone was different, people just did what they could.
其他人会发火、尖叫、退缩和哭泣。波莉只是看着，微笑着。她坐在感到恐惧的人身边，她的存在抚平了他们。她的笑容并不刻薄，而是理解。生活是地狱般的，她知道这一点。但她的笑容暗示她已经烧掉了一切。她的笑容带着一点优越感。我们没有勇气把自己烧掉，但她也理解这一点。每个人都不同，人们只是尽其所能。
One morning somebody was crying. But mornings were often noisy. Fights about getting up on time and complaints about nightmares. Polly was so quiet, so unobtrusive a presence that we didn't notice she wasn't at breakfast.
一天早上有人在哭。但早晨通常很吵。关于准时起床的争吵和关于噩梦的抱怨。波莉是如此安静、如此不引人注目，我们都没有注意到她没吃早餐。
After breakfast we could still hear crying. Who's crying? Nobody knew.
早餐后我们还能听到哭声。是谁在哭？没人知道。
And at lunch, there was still crying.
午餐时，依然有哭声。
"It's Polly," said Lisa, who knew everything.
“是波莉，”什么都知道的丽莎说。
Why? But even Lisa didn't know why.
为什么？但连丽莎都不知道为什么。
At dusk, the crying changed to screaming. Dusk is a dangerous time. At first she screamed, aah and ee! Then she started to scream words. My face, my face, my face!
黄昏时，哭声变成了尖叫。黄昏是一个危险的时间。起初她尖叫，“啊”和“诶”！然后她开始尖叫词语。“我的脸，我的脸，我的脸！”
We could hear other voices shushing her, murmuring comfort. But she continued to scream her two words long into the night.
我们能听到其他声音在嘘她，低声安慰她。但她整晚都在尖叫着这两个词。
Lisa said, "Well, I've been expecting this for a while."
丽莎说：“好吧，我早料到会这样了。”
And then I think we all realized what fools we'd been. We might get out some time, but she was locked up forever in that body.
然后我想我们都意识到自己有多蠢。我们也许有一天能出去，但她却被永远锁在了那具身体里。
Susanna Kaysen. Her book is called Girl, Interrupted.
苏珊娜·凯森。她的书名是《移魂女郎》。
[MUSIC- "YOU NEED AN ANALYST" BY ALLAN SHERMAN]
[音乐 - 艾伦·谢尔曼的《你需要一位分析师》]
Act Two, Guided by Voices.
第二幕，《幻听》。
Pat Deegan heard voices and she was a psychologist. When she was a girl the voices were friendly. She thought everybody heard voices. She didn't know that other people didn't.
帕特·迪根听到过声音，她是一位心理学家。当她是个女孩时，那些声音是友好的。她以为每个人都能听到声音。她不知道其他人听不到。
But when she turned 17, the voices changed. They became vicious, critical, unbearable. She was diagnosed as a schizophrenic.
但当她17岁时，那些声音变了。它们变得恶毒、挑剔、难以忍受。她被诊断为精神分裂症。
Years later, as a psychologist herself, she thought the only way mental health workers can really understand what their patients go through is if they hear the voices too. So she and some other people who hear voices got together to make a tape. They talked about the kinds of things the voices normally say to them and put together a script and had it recorded. And then they set up these training sessions where mental health workers would listen to this tape on a Walkman.
多年后，作为一名心理学家，她认为心理健康工作者想要真正理解患者的经历，唯一的方法就是让他们也能听到这些声音。于是她和其他一些听到声音的人聚在一起制作了一份录音带。他们讨论了那些声音通常对他们说的话，编写了脚本并录制下来。然后他们组织了培训课程，让心理健康工作者用随身听听这份录音。
And while they are listening to the voices, we also have them go through a mock psychiatric emergency services situation where they receive a mental status exam. They go to a mock psychological testing center where they do a reading comprehension test. They go to a mock day treatment program where they do some cognitive puzzles. And we also send them out into the community to have some kind of interaction. Get four quarters for a dollar, for instance, where they have to have some kind of social exchange with the public while experiencing these voices.
在他们听这些声音的同时，我们还会让他们经历模拟的精神科紧急服务情况，接受心理状态检查。他们去一个模拟的心理测试中心做阅读理解测试。他们去一个模拟的日间治疗项目做认知拼图。我们还会把他们派到社区去进行某种互动。比如，用一美元换取四个硬币，他们必须在体验这些声音的同时与公众进行社交往来。
And the actual voices that we're hearing on the tape, are these people who actually experience voices or they--
那么我们录音带里听到的声音，是那些真正经历这些声音的人，还是——
Yeah
是。
--actors? They are?
——演员？他们是吗？
These aren't actors, no. All of us were voice-hearers.
他们不是演员。我们所有人都是听见声音的人。
And are people simply reciting the voices that they themselves hear in their head sometimes?
人们只是在背诵他们自己脑海中偶尔听到的声音吗？
No, interestingly, we decided as a group that that's, for voice-hearers, much too dangerous a thing to do. People can actually internally get into enormous conflict and go into enormous crisis by revealing the content of what it is their voices are saying. Voices, very frequently, don't want to be broadcast all over the place. And so we had to take great care around that as voice-hearers ourselves.
不，有趣的是，我们作为一个群体认为，对于听见声音的人来说，那样做太危险了。人们如果揭露声音所说的内容，实际上会在内心陷入巨大的冲突并陷入严重的危机。声音通常并不希望被到处广播。所以作为听见声音的人，我们必须非常小心。
And so, for example, I think there's a man on there who says, you disgust me. That isn't his own-- that isn't what he, himself, hears, that's what somebody else might hear?
所以，举个例子，我想录音里有一个人说，“你让我感到恶心。”那不是他自己的——那不是他本人听到的，那是别人可能会听到的？
That's right.
没错。
That's right. That's right. Look at them. Their eyes are filled with disgust. They know how disgusting you are. Stop it now. Stop, stop, stop, stop. I see you. I see you. They see you. Everyone sees you. They hear you. They know you. They know how foul you are. Ugh. You are foul. Don't touch it. Don't touch it. Don't touch it. Don't touch it. Don't touch it.
没错。没错。看着他们。他们的眼睛里充满了厌恶。他们知道你有多恶心。现在停下。停下，停下，停下，停下。我看见你了。我看见你了。他们看见你了。每个人都看见你了。他们听见你了。他们认识你。他们知道你有多肮脏。呃。你真肮脏。别碰它。别碰它。别碰它。别碰它。别碰它。
The layering of voices on the tape, is that the way people actually experience this? That they'll hear several voices at once?
录音带里声音的重叠，是人们实际体验到的方式吗？他们会同时听到好几个声音？
Again, there's enormous individual variation with this. But it's not at all unusual for people to have more than one voice and to have more than one voice activated or talking at the same time.
同样，这存在巨大的个体差异。但一个人拥有不止一个声音，并且不止一个声音同时被激活或说话，这一点也不罕见。
Are the voices generally negative? Are they saying negative things?
声音通常是负面的吗？它们在说负面的话吗？
That seems to be a characteristic of people who are showing up for help with the voice-hearing experience, is that there aren't a predominance of helpful or good voices as we would call them.
这似乎是那些寻求帮助的听见声音者的一个特征，即并没有我们所称的“有帮助的”或“好的”声音占主导。
Filth, swine, disgusting garbage eater. I said you. Yeah, that's right. You stink. You stink. Filth, dirt, smirk, laughing, huh? You're not funny. You're pathetic. [LAUGHTER] You stink. Stinky, stinky, stink, stink. Stink. The only thing that's funny around here is you. That's right.
污秽、猪猡、恶心的垃圾食客。我说的是你。对，没错。你发臭。你发臭。污秽、脏东西、傻笑，哼？你一点也不有趣。你真可怜。[笑声]你发臭。臭气熏天，臭气熏天。发臭。这里唯一好笑的东西就是你。没错。
It's interesting because over the last few days, as a been thinking about this and listening to the tape and looking at your book, I've tried to be aware of whether in some low level way, I hear voices in my head. And I feel like I hear songs run through my head a lot more than I hear actual voices. And I was wondering if you view what voice-hearers experience as being just on a continuum from what everybody experiences in their everyday life?
很有趣，因为过去几天，当我思考这个问题，听着录音带并看着你的书时，我一直在试图意识到我的脑海里是否以某种低水平的方式听到了声音。我感觉我脑海里更多的是歌曲在流淌，而不是实际的声音。我想知道你是否认为听见声音的人的体验只是每个人日常生活中经历的一个连续体？
I think that the idea of a continuum is a nice one, but I'm afraid in this way I don't think it's accurate to talk about voice-hearing as being a continuum. The big, big, big difference between hearing the song in your head and having experience of hearing distressing voices is that first of all, in the truest sense of hearing, you don't hear it in the way that you hear my voice right now. The voice-hearing experience is first and foremost and most primordially, a profoundly auditory experience. To the point where you can actually startle if a voice starts up suddenly and you turn around and you're wondering where it all started, and if someone is actually in the room.
我认为“连续体”这个观点很好，但我恐怕在这一点上，谈论“幻听”是一个连续体是不准确的。脑海里听到歌曲和体验令人痛苦的声音之间有一个巨大、巨大、巨大的区别。首先，在听觉的真实意义上，你听到的方式与你现在听到我声音的方式并不一样。幻听体验首先也是最原始地，是一种深层的听觉体验。以至于如果一个声音突然响起，你会感到惊吓，你会转过身，想知道是从哪里发出的，以及房间里是否真的有人。
I feel silly that I didn't understand that up until this point. Somehow I had thought that what we were talking about were just simply-- I didn't realize that it was an auditory experience that one might confuse with actually hearing a sound in the room.
我感到很愚蠢，因为直到这一点我才明白。不知何故，我以为我们讨论的只是简单地——我没有意识到这是一种可能会与房间里实际听到的声音混淆的听觉体验。
Oh, absolutely. You absolutely hear it.
噢，当然。你绝对会听到它。
Hey, turn around and listen to me. Hey. Hey. Yeah, that's you I'm talking to. You're nothing. You know it's the truth too. You know it.
嘿，转过来听我说。嘿。嘿。对，我就是在跟你说话。你什么都不是。你也知道这是事实。你知道。
Oh. Ah. Ah, I can't stand it anymore. You are disgusting.
噢。啊。啊，我再也受不了了。你真恶心。
Slow down. Slow down. Slow down. Slow down. Slow down. Slow down. Get in the house. Go where you belong. Hide away. Hide away. You know what? You can't hide. You can't hide. They know where you are. They're going to find you no matter what you do. They know. You know. I know. We know. They all know. Stop it. Stop it.
慢下来。慢下来。慢下来。慢下来。慢下来。慢下来。进屋里去。去你该去的地方。躲起来。躲起来。你知道吗？你躲不掉的。你躲不掉的。他们知道你在哪儿。无论你做什么，他们都会找到你。他们知道。你知道。我知道。我们都知道。他们都知道。停下。停下。
Among the materials that you've put out, there's a pamphlet called, "Coping with Voices: Self-help Strategies for People Who Hear Voices That Are Distressing." You have advice for people who are hearing voices, the simple things that they can do. And one of them that you suggest is-- just to take a typical one here. One of them is using ear plugs. You say that some people have found that putting an ear plug in an ear can greatly reduce or eliminate distressing voices?
在你们发布的材料中，有一本名为《应对幻听：为听到令人痛苦声音的人准备的自助策略》的小册子。你为听到声音的人提供了建议，一些他们可以做的简单事情。你建议的一点是——就拿一个典型的例子来说。其中一个是使用耳塞。你说有些人发现，在耳朵里塞上耳塞可以极大地减少或消除令人痛苦的声音？
Yes, this is an interesting finding. And empirically what they've found is that putting the wax in both ears does not work. You have to try through trial and error, work with you right ear, then your left ear.
是的，这是一个有趣的发现。根据经验，他们发现两只耳朵都塞上蜡是不起作用的。你必须通过反复试验，处理你的右耳，然后是左耳。
For some people, for instance, putting it in the right ear, leaving it there for 15 minutes, will interrupt the voices. And in some cases, make them go away.
例如，对于有些人来说，把它塞在右耳，停留15分钟，就会打断声音。在某些情况下，让它们消失。
For other people you leave it in the right ear for 15 minutes and it's only when you take the plug out that the voices are interrupted and/or stop.
对于另一些人，你把它留在右耳15分钟，只有当你把耳塞取出来时，声音才会被打断和/或停止。
Do you have any thoughts about why it might work?
你对为什么它会起作用有什么想法吗？
No, I really don't.
没有，真的没有。
Is it just as simple as, well, let's just change the situation and just any change, like any physical change might help?
难道只是简单地，嗯，让我们改变一下情况，任何改变，比如任何物理改变都有帮助？
I think, frankly, after my studies and also through a lot of personal trial and error and learning experiences myself that there really is enormous truth that anything that promotes a sense of personal efficacy and power. That seems to be the key that these voices, which present themselves as the all-knowing, all-powerful, we know everything, we see everything you do, and on and on and on, to find that I can interrupt that powerful a force, really creates a space for me to have some power.
坦率地说，在我的研究之后，以及通过我自己的许多个人尝试、错误和学习经历，我认为确实存在巨大的真理，即任何能促进个人效能感和力量感的东西都很有价值。这似乎是关键所在。这些表现为无所不知、无所不能、我们知道一切、我们看到你所做的一切等等的声音，发现我竟然可以打断这样一股强大的力量，这确实为我创造了一些掌控权。
And of course, this flies in the face of what much of modern psychiatry is saying. That people who are experiencing major mental illness are having broken brains and can't possibly take a stand towards what's ailing them, except to take medications. I feel we're doing an enormous disservice in the United States in particular, by saying that medications are the only answer.
当然，这与现代精神病学所说的大相径庭。现代精神病学认为，患有严重精神疾病的人大脑受损，除了服用药物外，不可能对自己的病痛采取任何立场。我觉得我们在美国尤其造成了巨大的损害，因为我们说药物是唯一的答案。
Pat, do you talk about your own experiences of voice hear? I don't want to intrude in something that's private that you don't talk about publicly and ask you questions on this thing if you don't.
帕特，你谈论过你自己听到声音的经历吗？如果你不想公开谈论隐私，我就不在这方面问你问题了。
No, I do talk about it in some generality. Yes.
不，我确实在某种程度上谈论过它。是的。
In your own experience, have you successfully made voices go away completely? Do they come back sometimes for you?
在你自己的经历中，你成功地让声音完全消失了吗？它们有时会回来吗？
I live with distressing voices on almost a daily basis. Not 24 hours a day, but usually in the course of the day my voices do come. So, for instance, just before coming into this recording studio, I was sitting out in the waiting area. In the BUR offices. And there's a lot of what I would call white noise out there. White noise coming from a fan and a ventilation system in the room. And for me, that was very prominent. And for me and many other voice-heareres, a white noise situation is a set up for the emergence of distressing voices. So as that began to happen, I could say to myself, OK, it's going to be all right. I know I've got 10 minutes before the interview starts. And I pulled out an ear plug and I put it in my left ear, which is the ear that works for me. And I reassured myself that once I got out of the white noise situation that I would be doing better.
我几乎每天都要与这些令人痛苦的声音共处。不是24小时，但通常在一天中，声音确实会到来。例如，在进入这个录音室之前，我坐在等候区，在BUR办公室。外面有很多我所说的“白噪音”。来自房间里的风扇和通风系统的白噪音。对我来说，那非常突出。对于我和许多其他听到声音的人来说，白噪音的情况是令人痛苦的声音出现的诱因。所以当这种情况开始发生时，我可以对自己说：好的，没关系。我知道采访开始前我还有10分钟。我掏出一个耳塞塞进左耳，那是对我有效的一只耳朵。我安慰自己，一旦离开白噪音环境，我会好起来的。
How do you conceive of the voices that you hear? Do you conceive of them as being separate from yourself? Or do you conceive of them as being a part of yourself that you can recognize?
你是如何构想你听到的声音的？你认为它们与你自己是分开的吗？还是你认为它们是你自己可以识别的一部分？
I think that for me it's a goal to eventually be able to say these voices are a part of me. And that's actually one of the self-help coping strategies that I do use sometimes.
我认为对我来说，目标是最终能够说这些声音是我的一部分。这实际上是我有时使用的自助应对策略之一。
So, for instance, if I have a particularly derogatory, awful voice that I might say as a coping strategy, today I am feeling like I am no good. Today I am feeling like I'm a worthless person. These are my thoughts. These are my feelings.
所以，例如，如果我有一个特别贬损、糟糕的声音，我可能会将其作为一种应对策略说：今天我感觉自己很糟糕。今天我感觉自己是个毫无价值的人。这些是我的想法。这些是我的感受。
Is that because when the voice is saying that, literally you are not having the feeling, oh, I'm feeling bad today?
这是因为当声音那样说时，你字面上并没有“噢，我今天感觉很糟糕”的感觉吗？
That's right.
没错。
Wow.
哇。
Dr. Patricia Deegan. Her organization, The National Empowerment Center, can be reached at 1-800-POWER2YOU. That's 1-800, then the word "power", then the number "2", then the letter "U".
帕特里夏·迪根博士。她的组织“国家赋权中心”电话是1-800-POWER2YOU。即1-800，然后是单词“power”，然后是数字“2”，然后是字母“U”。
[MUSIC- "SEETHER" BY VERUCA SALT]
[音乐 - 维鲁卡·索尔特的《泡沫》]
Coming up, David Sedaris rocks, but not the way we usually mean when we say that. And other stories in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·塞达里斯摇滚起来了，但不是我们通常说的摇滚。更多故事将在片刻后来自国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course we choose a theme and invite a variety of writers, documentary producers, and performers to do stories on that theme. Today's program, on the edge of mental health. Stories of people who stand right at the border of sanity and sickness. We have arrived at Act Three of our program, Plague of Tics.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家、纪录片制片人和表演者围绕该主题讲述故事。今天的节目是关于心理健康的边缘。那些站在理智与疾病边缘的人们的故事。我们现在来到节目的第三幕，《抽动症瘟疫》。
Well, regular listeners to our show are familiar, very familiar, stunningly familiar, with David Sedaris. In the past, he's come onto the show to tell stories about getting the drama bug in high school, of his sister and mother deciding that they're going to solve crimes, of his first attempt, himself, at visiting a nudist colony. Today's story begins in grade school.
好吧，我们节目的常客对大卫·塞达里斯非常熟悉。过去，他曾上节目讲述他在高中时期迷上戏剧、他的姐姐和母亲决定要解决犯罪、他自己第一次尝试去参观天体主义者聚居地的故事。今天的故事从小学开始。
When the teacher asked if she might visit with my mother, I touched my nose eight times to the surface of my desk.
当老师问她是否可以拜访我的母亲时，我把鼻子在书桌表面碰了八下。
"May I take that as a yes?" she asked. According to her calculations, I had left my chair 28 times that day.
“我可以把它当作是肯定的回答吗？”她问。根据她的计算，那天我已经离开了座位28次。
"You're up and down like a flea. I turn my back for two minutes and there you are with your tongue pressed against that light switch. Maybe they do that where you come from, but here in my classroom we don't leave our seat and lick things whenever we please. That is Ms. Chestnut's light switch and she likes to keep it dry.
“你像只跳蚤一样上下乱跳。我转身才两分钟，你就把舌头贴在那个电灯开关上。也许在你们来的地方可以这么做，但在我的教室里，我们不能随意离开座位去舔东西。那是切斯特小姐的电灯开关，她喜欢保持它干燥。”
Would you like for me to come over to your house and put my tongue on your light switches? Well, would you?"
“你想让我去你家里，舔你的电灯开关吗？你想吗？”
I tried to picture her in action, but my shoe was calling.
我试着想象她那样做，但我的鞋子在召唤我。
"Take me off," it whispered. "Tap my heel against your forehead three times. Do it now. Quick. No one will notice."
“脱下我，”它低语道，“用我的鞋跟在你的额头上敲三下。快点。没人会注意到的。”
"Well?" Ms. Chestnut raised her faint penciled eyebrows. "I'm asking you a question. Would you or would you not want me licking the light switches in your house?"
“怎么了？”切斯特小姐抬起她浅浅的铅笔眉。“我在问你问题。你想还是不想让我舔你家里的电灯开关？”
I slipped off my shoe, pretending to examine the imprint on the heel.
我脱下鞋子，假装在检查鞋跟上的印记。
"You're going to hit yourself over the head with that shoe aren't you?"
“你打算用那只鞋敲自己的头，对吧？”
It wasn't hitting, it was tapping. But still, how would she known what I was about to do?
那不是敲，是点。但她是怎么知道我要做什么的？
"Heel marks all over your forehead," she said, answering my silent question.
“你额头上全是鞋印，”她说，回答了我没说出口的问题。
It was a short distance from the school to our rented house. No more than 637 steps. And on a good day, I could make the trip in an hour, pausing every few feet to tongue a mailbox or touch whichever single leaf or blade of grass demanded my attention.
从学校到我们租的房子距离很短。不超过637步。在顺利的一天里，我可以在一小时内走完这段路，每走几英尺就停下来舔舔邮箱，或者触摸任何一片单叶或草叶，如果它们要求我注意的话。
If I were to lose count of my steps, I'd have to return to the school and begin again. I might touch the telephone pole at step 314 and then 15 paces later, worry that I hadn't touched it in exactly the right spot. It needed to be touched again.
如果我数错了步数，就得回到学校重新开始。我可能会在第314步触碰电线杆，15步之后又担心没触碰到完全正确的位置。它需要再被触碰一次。
This was a long and complicated process. It demanded an oppressive attention to detail. Bypass that mailbox and my brain would never for one moment let me forget it.
这是一个漫长而复杂的过程。它需要对细节的压迫性关注。绕过那个邮箱，我的大脑就永远不会有一刻让我忘记它。
I might be sitting at the dinner table, daring myself not to think about it and the thought would revisit my mind. Don't think about it. But it was already too late and I knew then exactly what I had to do.
我可能坐在餐桌旁，强迫自己不要去想它，但那个念头又会回到脑海。别去想它。但这已经太迟了，那时我非常清楚自己该做什么。
Excusing myself to go to the bathroom, I'd walk out the front door and return to that mailbox. Not just touching, but jabbing. Practically pounding on the thing because I thought I hated it so much.
借口去洗手间，我会走出前门，回到那个邮箱。不是简单地触碰，而是猛戳。实际上是在敲打那东西，因为我想我非常讨厌它。
What I really hated, of course, was my mind. There must've been an off switch somewhere, but I was damned if I could find it.
当然，我真正讨厌的是我的大脑。一定有个开关在哪里，但我发誓我找不到它。
I didn't remember things being this way back north. Our family had been transferred from Endicott, New York, to Raleigh, North Carolina. That was a word used by the people at IBM, "transferred."
我不记得北边的时候事情是这样的。我们全家从纽约州恩迪科特被调到了北卡罗来纳州罗利市。那是IBM公司的人常用的词，“调动”。
A new home was under construction, but until it was finished we were confined to a rental property built to resemble a plantation house. The building sat in the treeless, balding yard. Its white columns promising a majesty the interior failed to deliver.
新房子正在建设中，但在它完工之前，我们被限制在一处为了模仿种植园房屋而建造的出租房里。那栋建筑坐落在没有树木、光秃秃的院子里。白色的柱子承诺着一种内部无法实现的宏伟。
The front door opened onto a dark, narrow hallway lined with bedrooms not much larger than the mattresses which furnished them.
前门打开是一个狭窄阴暗的走廊，两边排着卧室，比摆放它们的床垫大不了多少。
Once home I would touch the front door seven times with each elbow, a task made much more difficult if there was anyone else around.
回到家后，我会用每个手肘触碰前门七次，如果有别人在场，这项任务就会变得困难得多。
"Why don't you try the knob?" my sister Lisa would say. "That's what the rest of us do and it seems to work for us."
“你为什么不试试门把手？”我姐姐丽莎会说，“其他人都是这么做的，这招对我们很管用。”
Inside the house there were switches and door stops to be acknowledged. After kissing the 4th, 8th, and 12th carpeted stair, I wiped the cat hair from my lips and proceeded to the kitchen, where I was commanded to stroke the burners of the stove, press my nose against the refrigerator door, and arrange the percolator, toaster, and blender into a straight row.
房子里有需要确认的开关和门挡。在亲吻第4、第8和第12级铺着地毯的楼梯后，我擦掉嘴唇上的猫毛，继续走向厨房，那里我被要求抚摸炉子的燃烧器，用鼻子压在冰箱门上，并将咖啡壶、烤面包机和搅拌机摆成一条直线。
After making my rounds of the living room, it was time to kneel beside the banister and blindly jab a butter knife in the direction of my preferred electrical socket. There were bulbs to lick and bathroom faucets to test before finally I was free to enter my bedroom, where I would carefully align the objects on my dresser, lick the corners of my metal desk, and lie on my bed, rocking back and forth and thinking of what an odd woman she was, my third grade teacher, Ms. Chestnut.
在客厅走完一圈后，是时候跪在扶手旁，盲目地用一把黄油刀戳向我偏好的插座。在终于可以自由进入卧室之前，还有灯泡要舔，浴室水龙头要测试，在卧室里我会仔细对齐梳妆台上的物品，舔舔金属书桌的角落，躺在床上，来回摇晃，想着我三年级老师切斯特小姐是个多么古怪的女人。
Why come here and lick my light switches when she never used the one she had? Maybe she was drunk.
为什么来这里舔我的电灯开关，而她从不使用她自己的开关？也许她喝醉了。
On the afternoon that Ms. Chestnut arrived for her visit, I was in my bedroom rocking. Unlike the obsessive counting and touching, rocking was not a mandatory duty, but a voluntary and highly pleasurable exercise. It was my hobby and there was nothing else I would rather do.
在切斯特小姐来访的那个下午，我正在卧室里摇晃。与强制性的计数和触摸不同，摇晃不是必须的任务，而是一种自愿且极其令人愉悦的练习。这是我的爱好，没有别的我更想做的事情。
The point was not to rock oneself to sleep. This was not a step towards some greater goal, it was the goal itself. The perpetual movement freed my mind, allowing me to mull things over and construct elaborately detailed fantasies. Toss in a radio and I was content to rock until 3 or 4 o'clock in the morning, listening to the hit parade and discovering that each and every song was about me.
重点不是要把自己摇晃入睡。这不是迈向某个更大目标的步骤，它本身就是目标。不断的运动释放了我的思想，让我可以深思熟虑并构建详尽的幻想。如果再加上一台收音机，我就能满足于摇晃到凌晨3点或4点，听着热门歌曲排行榜，发现每一首歌都是关于我的。
I might have to listen 200 or 300 times to the same song, but sooner or later it's private message would reveal itself.
我可能得听同一首歌200或300遍，但迟早它的私人信息会显露出来。
I was coming to terms with "The Shadow of Your Smile" when Ms. Chestnut arrived. She rang the bell and I cracked open the bedroom door, watching as my mother invited her in.
我当时正在和《你的微笑的影子》达成和解，这时切斯特小姐到了。她按响了门铃，我把卧室门打开了一条缝，看着我母亲邀请她进去。
"You'll have to forgive me for these boxes," my mother flicked your cigarette out the door and into the littered yard. "They're filled with crap, every last one of them. But God forbid we throw anything away. Oh no, we can't do that. My husband saved it all." She mopped at her forehead with a wadded paper towel. "Anyway, to hell with it. You look like I need a drink. Scotch all right?" Ms. Chestnut's eyes brightened.
“你得原谅这些箱子，”我母亲把烟头弹出门外，落进垃圾遍地的院子里，“它们装满了垃圾，每一个都是。但上帝保佑我们别扔掉任何东西。噢不，我们不能那样做。我丈夫把这一切都留下了。”她用一张揉皱的纸巾擦着额头。“不管怎样，见鬼去吧。你看起来像我一样需要喝一杯。苏格兰威士忌可以吗？”切斯特小姐的眼睛亮了。
"I really shouldn't but, oh, why not?" She followed my mother up the stairs. "Just a drop with ice. No water."
“我真的不应该，但是，噢，为什么不呢？”她跟着我母亲上楼，“只要加点冰块的一点点。不要加水。”
I tried rocking in bed, but the sound of laughter drew me to the top of the landing, where from my vantage point behind an oversized wardrobe box, I watched the two women discuss my behavior.
我试着在床上摇晃，但笑声把我吸引到了楼梯平台顶部，在那里，从一个超大衣柜箱后面的有利位置，我看着这两个女人讨论我的行为。
"Oh, you mean the touching," my mother said. She opened her mouth just slightly, running her tongue over her upper lip, and then she inched forward, her index finger prodding the ash tray as though it were a sleeping thing she was trying to wake.
“噢，你是说触摸，”我母亲说。她微微张开嘴，舌头扫过上唇，然后她向前挪动，食指戳着烟灰缸，就好像它是一个她试图唤醒的沉睡东西。
I had never seen myself an action, but a sharp stinging sense of recognition told me that my mother's impersonation had been accurate.
我从未见过自己表演，但一种尖锐、刺痛的认同感告诉我，我母亲的模仿非常准确。
"God only knows where he gets it from," my mother said. "He's probably down in his room right this minute counting his eyelashes or gnawing at the poles on his dresser. 1, 2 o'clock in the morning and he'll still be at it, rattling around the house to poke the laundry hamper or press his face against the refrigerator door. The kid's wound too tight, but he'll come out of it. So what do you say, another scotch, Catherine?"
“上帝才知道他是从哪儿学来的，”我母亲说，“他现在可能正坐在楼下的房间里数睫毛，或者啃着梳妆台上的柱子。凌晨1点、2点，他还在弄，在屋里乱转，去戳脏衣篓，或者把脸贴在冰箱门上。这孩子绷得太紧了，但他会好起来的。你说呢，再来一杯苏格兰威士忌，凯瑟琳？”
Now she was Catherine. Another few drinks and she'd probably be joining us on our summer vacation. How easy it was for adults to bond over a second round of cocktails.
现在她是凯瑟琳了。再多喝几杯，她可能就会加入我们的暑假旅行了。成年人通过第二轮鸡尾酒建立联系是多么容易啊。
I returned to my bed, cranking up the radio so as not to be disturbed by the sound of their cackling.
我回到床上，调大收音机，以免被她们的咯咯笑声打扰。
Following Ms. Chestnut's visit, my father attempted to cure me with a series of threats. "You touch your nose to that windshield one more time and I'll guarantee you wish you hadn't," he said, driving home from the grocery store with a lot full of rejected, out of state coupons. It was virtually impossible for me to ride in the passenger seat of a car and not press my nose against the windshield. And now that the activity had been forbidden, I wanted it more than anything.
在切斯特小姐来访后，我父亲试图用一系列威胁来治好我。“你再把鼻子碰那个挡风玻璃一次，我保证你会后悔的，”他在从杂货店开车回家的路上说道，车里装满了被拒绝的、外州的优惠券。对我来说，坐在汽车副驾驶座位上而不把鼻子压在挡风玻璃上简直是不可能的。现在这个活动被禁止了，我比什么都想要它。
I tried closing my eyes, hoping that might eliminate my desire, but found myself thinking that perhaps he was the one who should close his eyes. So what if I wanted to touch my nose to the windshield? Who was it hurting? Why was it that he could repeatedly worry his change and bite his lower lip without the threat of punishment?
我试着闭上眼睛，希望能消除我的欲望，但发现自己想的却是，也许他才是那个应该闭上眼睛的人。所以如果我想把鼻子压在挡风玻璃上，那又怎样？它伤害了谁？为什么他可以反复摆弄零钱、咬下嘴唇而不用担心惩罚？
My mother smoked and Ms. Chestnut massaged her waist 20, 30 times a day. And here, I couldn't press my nose against the windshield of a car?
我母亲抽烟，切斯特小姐每天按摩腰部20、30次。而在这里，我却不能把鼻子压在汽车挡风玻璃上？
I opened my eyes, defiant. But when he caught me moving towards my target, my father slammed on the brakes.
我睁开眼睛，挑衅地。但当他发现我正向目标移动时，我父亲猛地踩下了刹车。
"You like that, did you?" He handed me a golf towel to wipe the blood from my nose. "Did you like the feel of that?"
“你喜欢那个，是吗？”他递给我一条高尔夫毛巾擦掉鼻子上的血，“你喜欢那种感觉吗？”
Like was too feeble a word for what I felt. I loved it. If mashed with the right amount of force, a blow to the nose can be positively narcotic.
“喜欢”这个词对于我的感受来说太无力了。我爱死它了。如果用力适当，给鼻子一击可以产生积极的麻醉作用。
Touching objects satisfied a mental edge, but the task involved a great deal of movement. Run upstairs, cross the room, remove a shoe. I soon found these same urges could be fulfilled within the confines of my own body. Punching myself in the nose was a good place to start. But the practice was dropped when I began rolling my eyes deep into their sockets, an exercise that provided quickly jolts of dull, intoxicating pain.
触碰物体满足了一种心理边缘，但这个任务涉及大量的运动。跑上楼、穿过房间、脱鞋。我很快发现同样的欲望可以在我身体的限制内得到满足。打自己的鼻子是个很好的开始。但这练习在我开始把眼球转进眼眶深处时就被放弃了，这是一种能迅速提供迟钝、令人陶醉的疼痛的练习。
"I know exactly what you're talking about," my mother said to Ms. Shatts, my visiting fourth grade teacher. "The eyes rolling every which way. It's like talking to a slot machine. Hopefully one day it'll pay off, but until then what do you say we have ourselves another glass of wine?"
“我完全知道你在说什么，”我母亲对我来访的四年级老师沙茨小姐说，“眼睛向各个方向滚动。就像在和一台老虎机说话。希望有一天它会回报，但在此之前，我们要不要再来一杯酒？”
I took to violently shaking my head, startled by the feel of my brain slamming against the confines of my skull. It felt so good and took so little time, just a few quick jerks and I was satisfied for up to 45 seconds at a time.
我开始猛烈地摇晃头部，被大脑撞击颅骨限制的感觉吓了一跳。这种感觉太棒了，而且花的时间很少，只需要几次快速的抽动，我就能在长达45秒的时间里感到满足。
"Have a seat and let me get you something cool to drink." My mother would leave my fifth, and then my sixth grade teacher standing in the breakfast nook while she stepped into the kitchen to crack open a tray of ice. "I'm guessing you're here about the head shaking, am I right?" she'd shout. "That's my boy, all right. No flies on him."
“坐下，让我给你拿点凉的喝。”我母亲会让我的五年级，然后是六年级老师站在早餐角，而她则走进厨房去敲开一盘冰。“我猜你是为摇头而来的，对吧？”她会喊道，“那是我儿子，没错。他一点也不笨。”
This was part of my mother's act. She played the ringleader, blowing the whistle and charming the crowd with her jokes and exaggerated stories. "It's a stretch, but I'm betting you're here about the tiny voices," she said, offering a glass of sherry to my visiting seventh grade teacher. "I'm thinking of either taken him to an exorcist or buying him a doll, so he can bring some money as a ventriloquist."
这是我母亲表演的一部分。她扮演领头羊，吹着哨子，用她的笑话和夸张的故事吸引人群。“这有点夸张，但我敢打赌你是为那些小声音而来的，”她对着来访的七年级老师提供雪利酒时说，“我在考虑要么带他去看驱魔人，要么给他买个玩偶，这样他能带点钱作为腹语表演者。”
It had come out of nowhere, my desperate urge to summon high-pitched noises from the back of my throat. These were not words, but sounds that satisfied an urge I'd never before realized. The sounds were delivered not in my voice, but in that of a thimble-sized, temperamental diva clinging to the base of my uvula.
它不知从哪儿冒出来的，我那种迫切想从喉咙深处发出高音调噪音的欲望。这些不是话，而是满足了我从未意识到的欲望的声音。这些声音不是用我的嗓音发出的，而是出自一个粘在我小舌底部的、像顶针一样大的、喜怒无常的女歌唱家之口。
[MAKING NOISES]
[发出噪音]
I was host to these wailing, but lacked the ability to control them. When I cried out in class, the teachers would turn from the blackboards with increasingly troubled expressions. "Is somebody rubbing a balloon? Who's making that noise?"
我是这些哭号的主人，但缺乏控制它们的能力。当我在课堂上哭喊时，老师们会带着越来越困惑的表情从黑板前转过身来。“是谁在摩擦气球？谁在制造那种噪音？”
I'd like to think that some of my nervous habits faded during high school, but my class pictures tell a different story. "Draw in the missing eyeballs and this one might not be so bad," my mother would say.
我愿意认为我的一些神经性习惯在高中时期消失了，但我的班级照片说明了另一个故事。“画上缺失的眼珠，这一张可能就不会那么糟糕了，”我母亲会说。
In group shots I was easily identified as the blur in the back row. For a time I thought that if I accompanied my habits with an outlandish wardrobe, I might be viewed as eccentric rather than just plain retarded. I was wrong.
在集体照中，我很容易被识别为后排的模糊点。有一段时间，我想如果我把我的习惯配上一套古怪的服装，我可能会被视为古怪而不是仅仅被称为迟钝。我错了。
Only a confirmed idiot would wander the halls of my high school dressed in a floor length caftan. And as for the countless medallions that hung around my neck, I might as well have worn a cow bell. They clanged and jangled with every jerk of my head, calling attention when without them I might have passed unnoticed. My oversize glasses did nothing but provide a clearer view of my rolling, twitching eyes, and the chunky platform shoes left lumps when used to discreetly tap my forehead. I was a mess.
只有一个确凿的白痴才会穿着长及地面的长袍在高中走廊里徘徊。至于我脖子上挂着的无数奖章，我不如直接戴个牛铃。它们随着我头的每一次抽动而叮当作响，吸引着注意力，如果不戴它们，我可能根本不会被注意到。我的超大号眼镜除了提供一个更清晰的视角来观察我滚动、抽搐的眼睛外什么都没做，厚底鞋在用来悄悄敲击我的前额时留下了肿块。我真是个烂摊子。
"College is the best thing that can ever happen to you," my father used to say. And he was right. For it was there that I discovered drugs, drinking, and smoking.
“大学是能发生在你身上最好的事情，”我父亲过去常说。他是对的。因为正是在那里，我发现了毒品、喝酒和吸烟。
I'm unsure of the scientific aspects, but for some reason my nervous habits faded at around the same time I took up with cigarettes. Maybe it was coincidental, or perhaps the tics retreated in the face of an adversary that, despite its health risks, is much more socially acceptable than crying out in tiny voices.
我不确定科学方面的原因，但出于某种原因，我的神经性习惯在大约我开始吸烟的同时消失了。也许是巧合，或者也许抽动在面对一个虽然有健康风险、但在社交上比哭着发出细小声音更容易被接受的对手时退缩了。
It's as if I'd been born to smoke. And until I realized that my limbs were left to search for some alternative, everything's fine as long as I know there's a cigarette in my immediate future.
就好像我天生就是为了抽烟。在意识到我的四肢必须去寻找某种替代品之前，只要我知道在不久的将来有一支烟，一切都很好。
The people who ask me not to smoke in their cars have no idea what they're in for.
那些要求我不要在他们车里吸烟的人根本不知道他们会遇到什么。
David Sedaris' story, "Plague  of Tics" is in his book, Naked.
大卫·塞达里斯的故事《抽动症瘟疫》收录在他的书《赤裸》中。
[MUSIC-"PSYCHO" BY ELVIS COSTELLO]
[音乐 - 艾维斯·卡斯提洛的《精神病》]
Act Four, You Don't Have to Be Crazy to Work Here, But It Helps.
第四幕，《你不需要疯也能在这里工作，但有病会有帮助》。
When he was in his 20, Joel Lovell had a job in a mental hospital helping care for patients. Usually he worked days, nights he says, were different.
乔尔·洛弗尔20多岁时，在一家精神病院工作，负责照顾病人。通常他上白班，他说，晚上是不同的。
We often made fun of the night staff. Said that they were as crazy as the patients. There was Joe, the monosyllabic bodybuilder, and John, the pathological liar, and Shawn, who arrived each night for his shift raw-throated and near tears from his own afternoon session of scream therapy. Between midnight and seven we'd say, it wasn't at all clear who should be carrying the keys.
我们经常取笑夜班员工。说他们和病人一样疯。有单音节的健美运动员乔，有病态说谎者约翰，还有肖恩，他每天晚上来轮班时都嗓子沙哑，离泪崩只有一步之遥，因为他自己下午刚进行过尖叫治疗。午夜到七点之间我们说，谁该拿着钥匙完全不清楚。
The suggestion, of course, was that during the day it was clear. And that those of us who carried the keys, the shrinks from Harvard, the nurses in charge of the floor, even the lowly mental health workers like myself, were all models of sanity in the midst of so much chaos.
当然，这暗示在白天是很清楚的。那些携带钥匙的人——哈佛的精神科医生、负责楼层的护士，甚至像我这样地位低下的心理健康工作者，都是混乱中理智的典范。
We had keys to everything. There was a key to the front door and a key to the nurse's station. There were keys to the therapy offices and to the linen closet and to the staff bathroom across from the quite rooms, two windowless, white isolation areas to which we also had keys. And of course, there was the restraint key, a thin pointed silver thing, more like a tiny pocketknife than a key that slipped into the buckle of the straps we used to secure a patient's limbs to the corners of a metal bed.
我们有通往一切的钥匙。有大门的钥匙和护士站的钥匙。有治疗办公室、储物间和安静房间对面的员工卫生间的钥匙，那是两个没有窗户、白色的隔离区，我们也持有那里的钥匙。当然，还有约束钥匙，那是一种细长尖锐的银色东西，更像一把小折刀而不是钥匙，它能滑进我们用来将病人四肢固定在金属床角落的带扣里。
If a patient wanted to use the toaster, we had the key. If they wanted to use their own nail clippers, they were kept in a cabinet and we had the key.
如果病人想用烤面包机，我们有钥匙。如果他们想用自己的指甲刀，它们会存放在柜子里，我们有钥匙。
During the day, we moved through the hall like a team of custodians, rousting patients out of bed, urging them to shower and dress and brush their teeth. To attend, in hospital parlance, to their activities of daily living. We ushered them into large group meetings and small group meetings. Meetings in which we discussed the dynamics on the hall, meetings in which we explained the effects of medication, meetings in which patients were often told news they didn't want to hear. That they would have to endure another round of electro shock therapy. That they were not well enough to attend their daughter's birthday party. That for yet another week, they would not be allowed to do almost anything unsupervised.
白天，我们像清洁工团队一样在走廊里穿梭，把病人从床上叫起来，催促他们洗澡、穿衣、刷牙。在医院的术语中，参加他们的“日常生活活动”。我们引导他们参加大型团体会议和小型团体会议。讨论病房动态的会议，解释药物影响的会议，病人经常被告知他们不想听到的消息的会议。他们将不得不忍受另一轮电休克治疗。他们健康状况不足以参加女儿的生日聚会。他们还要再被禁闭一周，几乎不允许做任何没有监督的事情。
It was a place where much more often than not, short-term hopes were dashed, ineffably sad outcomes were commonplace. And anger over illnesses that no one knew precisely how to treat could erupt spontaneously.
这是一个短期希望常常破灭、无法言喻的悲伤结果司空见惯的地方。对无人知晓如何治疗的疾病的愤怒可能会自发地爆发。
We were constantly gauging the mood of the hall in the way that I imagine desperate farmers gauge the mood of the skies and reacting accordingly. There has to be more of a staff presence on the hall someone would say. Meaning that there was a palpable tension on the unit, a sense of danger in the air. And that rather than spending time back in the nurse's station blowing off steam and catching up on notes, we had to make our presence known out on the floor.
我们不断地评估病房的气氛，就像我想象中绝望的农民评估天空的气氛一样，并做出相应的反应。“病房里需要更多的员工，”有人会说。这意味着病房里有一种明显的紧张气氛，空气中有一种危险感。而不是回到护士站发泄情绪和整理记录，我们必须让我们的存在出现在病房里。
Occasionally, for extra money, I'd work nights. Everything about the place seemed different at night. It's a sentimental notion, I know. But I could never quite shake the sense when driving through the front gate for a night shift of entering a parallel universe, a place where all the day's demons were laid to rest. Where medicines worked. Where minds were calmed. Where the safe haven we tried so hard to create during the day was actually made real.
有时，为了额外的钱，我会上夜班。这里的一切在晚上看起来都不同。我知道这是一种感伤的观念。但当驱车穿过大门去上夜班时，我总是无法摆脱进入一个平行宇宙的感觉，一个所有白天的恶魔都被平息的地方。药物发挥作用的地方。头脑变得平静的地方。我们在白天辛苦创造的安全港湾在晚上真正实现的地方。
I'd drive slowly along the winding road to our unit and look out at the moon on the snow, at the lights on here and there in the red brick buildings across the hospital grounds. And I'd think that, for all the terrors a place like this connotes, it couldn't possibly look more welcoming, less coldly clinical than it did in the middle of the night. Night, of course, can have this effect anywhere. Exhaustion finally wins out over struggle. But the sense of calm that settled in at the hospital always surprised me.
我会慢慢开车沿着弯曲的道路驶向我们的病房，看着雪地上的月光，看着医院地面上那些红砖建筑里忽明忽暗的灯光。我会想，尽管这样一个地方意味着所有恐惧，但在半夜里，它不可能看起来比这更受欢迎，比这更不冷酷。当然，夜晚在任何地方都能产生这种效果。精疲力竭最终战胜了挣扎。但医院里平静下来的那种感觉总是让我惊讶。
The job at night, such as it was, consisted mostly of just staying awake. If you were the staff member on checks, you were responsible for knowing where each patient was. You sat in the foyer with a flashlight and every 30 minutes made a tour from one end of the unit to the other, poking your head into each darkened room and shining a quick bloom of light on the patients asleep in their beds. It was a simple, remarkable thing to see, people in so much pain sleeping peacefully.
夜班工作，大抵如此，大部分时间就是保持清醒。如果你是负责查房的员工，你就有责任知道每个病人的位置。你坐在门厅里拿着手电筒，每30分钟进行一次巡回，从病房的一端到另一端，把头探进每个黑暗的房间，给睡在床上的病人照上一道快速的微光。这是一种简单、非凡的事情，看到那些承受着如此大痛苦的人平静地睡觉。
There was Barbara, the reverend's wife, who previously had snuck in a utility razor and cut a five inch gash into the sole of her foot.
有芭芭拉，那位牧师的妻子，她之前曾偷偷带进一把工具刀，在脚底割了一个五英寸长的伤口。
And there was Tim, the former track star, who had gained so much weight from taking anti-psychotic meds that he'd spend hours each day with this high school yearbook in his lap, open to a page that had a photo of some graceful, muscled kid who looked vaguely like him.
还有蒂姆，那位前田径明星，他因为服用抗精神病药物体重增加了很多，以至于他每天花几个小时把高中年鉴放在膝盖上，翻开那一页，照片里有个优雅、肌肉发达的孩子，长得有点像他。
There was Ann, and Mike, and there was Carol, who's sister came every Thursday afternoon. Whenever she visited, I'd watch them in the foyer. Carol's sister talking and Carol staring out from behind her thick glasses, smoking cigarette after cigarette. Her face, her hair, like a smudged version of the attractive woman sitting next to her.
有安、迈克，还有卡罗尔，她姐姐每周四下午都来看她。每当她来访时，我都会在门厅里看着她们。卡罗尔的姐姐在说话，而卡罗尔戴着厚厚的眼镜从后面盯着，一根接一根地抽烟。她的脸，她的头发，就像旁边坐着的那个有吸引力的女人的污点版本。
My own brother, the person I loved most in the world, was a patient in a psych hospital in Saratoga, New York. It seems obvious now, though I couldn't quite articulate it to myself at the time, that I worked where I did not because, as I told myself, it would help me on my applications to medical school. But because it allowed me to be both closer to my brother and more distanced from him. To understand in some vaguely intimate way what he was suffering and to reassure myself that I was, in fact, safe from his madness. That I was so sane I carried the keys.
我自己的哥哥，我在这世界上最爱的人，是纽约州萨拉托加一家精神病院的病人。现在看起来很明显，尽管当时我无法向自己表达清楚，我之所以在那里工作，不是像我告诉自己那样因为它能帮助我申请医学院。而是因为它让我既能更接近我哥哥，又能与他保持距离。以某种模糊的亲密方式理解他所遭受的痛苦，并向自己保证我确实是安全的，远离他的疯狂。我太理智了，所以我带着钥匙。
Whenever I visited him, I couldn't stop myself from imagining us like Carol and her sister, his Goofus to my Gallant. And the thought both comforted me and filled me with shame.
每当我去看他时，我就无法停止想象我们就像卡罗尔和她的姐姐一样，他是我的“傻瓜”，我是他的“高尚者”。这种想法既安慰了我，又让我充满了羞耻。
After I checked on the last patient, I'd go back to the foyer and bide my time. I'd sit and drink coffee and watch the clock, waiting for the next half hour to tick by. Or I'd find a deck of cards on one of the shelves and play solitaire. Or sometimes I'd try writing letters to my brother that I never sent. Opening them with some bad joke about how at that moment, both of us were in a hospital, but he was probably deep into sleep and I was the one up scribbling nonsense.
检查完最后一个病人后，我会回到门厅打发时间。我会坐着喝咖啡看时钟，等待下一个半小时到来。或者我会在架子上找一副牌玩纸牌游戏。有时我会试着写信给我哥，但从没寄出去过。打开它们，带着一些烂笑话，说那时我们俩都在医院，但他可能已经睡熟了，而我是那个还在乱涂乱画的。
Sometimes late in the night, it could feel like I, too, was starting to unravel. I'd go into the nurses station and pull charts and read my notes from the day shifts. I'd focus on their authoritative tone.
有时在深夜，感觉就像我也开始崩溃了。我会走进护士站拿病历，读我白班的记录。我会专注于那种权威的口吻。
Patient oriented to time, place, self. But continues to ruminate about radio messages being sent through her braces.
“病人对时间、地点、自身有定向力。但继续反复思考通过牙套发送的无线电信息。”
Patient remains highly paranoid, fears government is poisoning him through hospital food.
“病人依然高度偏执，担心政府通过医院食物对他投毒。”
At the end of most of my night shifts, my notes were all the same. Patient slept. Patient slept. Patient slept.
在我大多数夜班的最后，我的记录都是一样的。“病人睡觉。病人睡觉。病人睡觉。”
On the last night shift I worked I fell asleep while on checks-- the one mistake a night worker was never supposed to make. I was probably out for 45 minutes, long enough theoretically for something terrible to happen. I woke to Carol standing in front of me in her night gown, a cigarette in hand. "I need a light," she said. And then she sat down next to me near the foyer and made fun of me for falling asleep.
在我工作的最后一个夜班，我在查房时睡着了——这是夜班工人永远不该犯的唯一错误。我可能睡了45分钟，从理论上讲足够发生可怕的事情。我在卡罗尔穿着睡袍站在我面前醒来，手里拿着一根烟。“我需要火，”她说。然后她坐在门厅附近我身边，取笑我睡着了。
"Go lie down," she said. "Ive got everything under control here."
“去躺下吧，”她说，“这里一切都在我的控制之下。”
She wasn't wearing her glasses and her hair was pulled back. Her disheveledness seemed normal in the middle of the night, the way any of us look when we shuffle in half sleep from our beds to the kitchen or bathroom.
她没戴眼镜，头发向后扎着。她的凌乱在半夜看起来很正常，就像我们任何人在半睡半醒中从床上移步到厨房或卫生间时看起来的那样。
I'd been having a dream in which a party was going on in a hospital, though not the one where I worked. Patients were coming out of their rooms in ball gowns and tuxes and my brother was there, looking happy and handsome.
我做了一个梦，梦见医院里正在举办派对，虽然不是我工作的那家。病人们穿着舞会礼服和燕尾服走出房间，我哥也在那儿，看起来很高兴、很帅气。
Now the pleasantness of the dream was fading and Carol must've been able to see it on my face. She asked me what was wrong and because it was 5:00 AM and because I was exhausted and nauseous and not my appropriate daytime self, I told that I'd been dreaming of my brother and that he was in a hospital sick.
现在梦中的愉快正在褪去，卡罗尔一定能从我的脸上看出来。她问我怎么了，因为那时是凌晨5点，因为我精疲力竭、反胃，而且不是我正常白天的样子，我告诉她我梦见了我哥，他病倒在医院里。
"In the body or the head?" she asked.
“在身体上还是脑子里？”她问。
"The head," I said.
“脑子里，”我说。
She nodded knowingly, took a tremendous drag on her cigarette, and blew a cloud of smoke out over the two of us.
她若有所思地点点头，深深地吸了一口烟，向我们俩吹出一团烟雾。
"He'll be all right," she said, in what seemed to me to be the sanest tone I'd ever heard her speak. "We'll all be all right."
“他会好起来的，”她说，用一种在我听来她曾用过的最理智的语调，“我们都会好起来的。”
Carol finished her cigarette went back to bed. I did some jumping jacks in the foyer in order to stay awake. Eventually the sky began to lighten. The day staff came in with snow melting on their shoes.
卡罗尔抽完烟回到床上。我在门厅里做了些开合跳以保持清醒。最后天空开始变亮。白班员工带着鞋上融化的雪走了进来。
They crowded into the nurse's station for the change of shift report. I stood there for a while watching the quick nods, the efficient division of responsibility. I considered saying something about Carol, about how lucid she'd seemed to me just a couple of hours ago. It wasn't so extraordinary, I knew. But still, I wanted the conversation on record.
他们挤进护士站进行交接班报告。我站在那儿看了一会儿快速的点头和高效的任务分配。我考虑说点关于卡罗尔的事，关于几个小时前她看起来有多清醒。我知道这并不太非凡。但不管怎样，我想把这段对话记录在案。
On the way out I stopped to see Carol. She was awake and eating breakfast, and I wanted to thank her for our conversation.
离开的路上，我停下来去看卡罗尔。她醒着正在吃早餐，我想感谢我们的谈话。
"I appreciate what you said earlier, Carol."
“我很感激你之前说的话，卡罗尔。”
She didn't look up. She was preparing for cereal and muttering to herself, something about the children's book, Johnny Tremain , that she'd been reading over and over for the past several weeks. I thanked her again and again she didn't look up.
她没有抬头。她正准备吃麦片，嘴里嘟囔着什么关于儿童读物《约翰尼·垂梅恩》的事，那是过去几周她一直在反复读的书。我又感谢了她一次，她还是没抬头。
When I left the room, she was pouring sugar in huge spoonfuls over her Apple Jacks.
当我离开房间时，她正把大勺大勺的糖倒在她的苹果杰克斯麦片上。
Joel Lovell lives in Brooklyn.
乔尔·洛弗尔住在布鲁克林。
Well, our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel and myself with Peter Clowney and Nancy Updike. Additional production and editing by Susan Burton.
好吧，我们今天的节目由亚历克斯·斯皮格尔和我本人，以及彼得·克劳尼和南希·厄普代克共同制作。由苏珊·伯顿进行额外制作和编辑。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Musical help from Peter Margasak, John Connors and Sarah Vowell. To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ Chicago 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site.
音乐协助由彼得·玛加萨克、约翰·康纳斯和萨拉·沃维尔提供。如需购买此节目或我们任何节目的盒式录音带，请拨打我们芝加哥WBEZ电话312-832-3380。或者您可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢管理网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who has this advice for all our listeners--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他给所有听众的建议是——
If mashed with the right amount of force, a blow to the nose can be positively narcotic.
如果用力适当，给鼻子一击可以产生积极的麻醉作用。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
Like was too feeble a word for what I felt. I loved it.
“喜欢”这个词对于我的感受来说太无力了。我爱死它了。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。